bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
session d'information voilà ce que l'on
peut retenir en ce mercredi 13 mai 3e
édition des Trophées de la mobilité la
casquille la CCI des Yvelines et
l'association d'entreprises deltaski
sont lauréate dans la catégorie réduire
les nuisances de la circulation
automobile les régionales sans décembre
prochain mais les candidats se
bousculent déjà l'UMP Valérie Pécresse
le socialiste Claude Bartolone et c'est
au tour de Nicolas Dupont-Aignan de
lancer sa campagne en Île-de-France et
puis le cinquième prix poésieveling des
collégiens bien d'être remis à une
hauteur québécoise 400 élèves de tout le
département ayant participé et nous
débutons donc cette édition avec un prix
celui des Trophées de la mobilité remis
hier conjointement à la casquille à la
CCI à des Yvelines à l'association
d'entreprise deltaski pour leur démarche
d'élaboration et d'animation de PDE
entendait plein de déplacement interne
entreprise aujourd'hui à 5 secteurs
géographiques sont couverts par un PDE
et 50000 personnes soit près de la
moitié des salariés du territoire de
Saint-Quentin bénéficie de mesures
d'amélioration de leur mobilité créée en
2013 ces Trophées de la mobilité sont
organisés par le STIF en partenariat
avec la région
Île-de-France l'objectif est de
valoriser les bonnes pratiques dans le
domaine des transports et de la mobilité
et bien sûr de mettre en avant les
actions réalisées sur le territoire
francilien ils devront s'il en est
encore question avec les candidats aux
régionales et régionales c'est pour le
mois de mars prochain après Valérie
Pécresse pour l'UMP Claude Bartholome
pour le Parti socialiste ou encore
Chantal jouannou pour l'UDI c'est au
tour de Nicolas Dupont-Aignan pour
debout la France de se déclarer Mélanie
poquet et William elle était présent
lors de l'ouverture de son QG de
campagne à Paris
pas deux surprises Nicolas Dupont-Aignan
et le candidat tête de liste de Debout
la France pour la région Île-de-France
la volonté particulière c'est que je
veux qu'on reprenne les clés
l'Île-de-France et qu'on les rende au
franciliens et le deuxième volonté
particulière sur l'Île-de-France et
qu'on s'occupe des projets assez des
projets mégalomaniaques moi je veux
chose simple je suis maire de banlieue
je veux que le RER marche je veux qu'à
l'hôpital public ça soit pas le bazar
j'en ai assez des trafiquants de drogue
et je vais en Seine-Saint-Denis pour
qu'on les nettoie lors des régionales de
2010 la liste conduite par Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan avait recueilli 4 % des
suffrages loin du Parti socialiste sorti
dans le cœur et de l'UMP on dit aux
Français il y a autre chose c'est déjà
pas mal et c'est un énorme effort
financier un énorme effort de nos
militants pour être présent partout
voilà on va vous offrir autre chose
après c'est à vous de choisir le député
maire de Hyères dans l'Essonne devrait
présenter plusieurs yvelinois sur sa
liste
et puis toujours en politique pierre
Bédié président du conseil départemental
des Yvelines a été désignée ce mercredi
1er des vice-présidents de l'Assemblée
des départements de France aux côtés du
nouveau président de l'ADF Dominique
Bussereau pierre-bédian compte explique
dans un communiqué de presse pour suivre
son combat pour défendre la place des
départements en France allez direction
trappes maintenant ce mercredi
après-midi on a couru pour la bonne
cause l'association Action contre la
Faim organisée sa traditionnelle course
contre la faim dans le monde les enfants
étaient invités à venir effectuer
quelques kilomètres pour récolter de
l'argent au profit de projet
humanitaires et puis aujourd'hui ce sont
plus de 200 jeunes qui ont fait le
déplacement au stade Gibert Gensac de
trappes et nous allons écouter le
référent de l'association à des propos
recueillis par William L
chaque année s'occupe d'un pays qui
souffre de famine dû aux guerres dû aux
épidémies dû aux intempéries cette année
action contre la fin s'occupe du pays le
Burkina Faso les jeunes d'abord
récupèrent un prospect pour retrouver un
par un parrain qu'il est qu'il est
sponsorisera partout et à la fin on
multipliera le nombre de tours par la
Somme et on aura la somme totale
récoltée par chaque enfant l'année
dernière on a récolté à peu près plus de
400 euros nous accueillons des enfants
dans nos structures de 10 ans maximum va
rendre à 11 ans mais de là avoir des 12
14 ans venir de leur propre chef
quasiment auto sponsorisé pour être avec
avec nous aujourd'hui venir se dépenser
une heure c'est pas rien de venir une
heure
c'est vraiment un don de soi voilà voilà
on voit un référent motivé par cette
course contre la fin c'était donc cet
après-midi attrape on ouvre maintenant
une page culture ce mercredi remise du
5e prix poésievelin des collégiens au
théâtre de 50 ans en Yvelines ou une
auteur québécoise a été récompensée 450
collégiens ont participé
tu es fait de cendres de poussière ou te
mènera donc ton en conscience je suis né
de l'armée de rêve des jolis mots lu par
les membres du club Jeune Théâtre de
Voisins le bretonneux un texte signé
d'une hauteur inoupe peuple francophone
du Nord du Québec Rita mesto-cocho
l'oréade du 5e prix poésie l'une des
collégiens l'auteur n'était pas présent
pour recevoir son prix mais pour
l'éditeur français qui a publié son
travail c'est une vraie reconnaissance
Vitaa c'était aussi c'était aussi appuyé
en faveur des peuples en voie de
disparition donc les iNous et aussi ce
qui nous a touché c'est ça sa poésie la
fois très simple authentique il y a un
côté aussi très chamanique donc il parle
des forêts de l'eau de du vent mais
aussi des sentiments comme l'amour la
haine l'auteur il nous fait partie des
quatre auteurs sélectionnés pour
participer à ce concours très collège du
département ont été concernés 450 élèves
ont tous sollicité pour lire les textes
on apporte
ce plus dans les établissements
scolaires de la lecture d'une écriture
contemporaine qui parle d'eux qui parle
de ce qu'ils sont de ce qu'ils font avec
un choix très particulier et
volontairement de livres qui ne sont pas
obligatoirement des livres destinés pour
la jeunesse même surtout pas du tout
destiné à la jeunesse pour leur ouvrir
aussi à une écriture adulte et parmi les
élèves qui ont participé au concours une
classe en particulier ces mobilisée la
troisième c'est pas du collège des
saules de Guyancourt ils ont travaillé
toute l'année sur un projet d'écriture
autour de l'autoportrait pour ses élèves
en difficulté scolaires la poésie s'est
exprimée ses émotions
c'est important pour eux je pense qu'ils
ont du mal eux-mêmes à les exprimer donc
de pouvoir lire des auteurs
effectivement qui expriment leurs
propres émotion eux je pense que ça les
touche particulièrement et c'est vrai
que nous on a fait le lien après avec
les ateliers d'écriture ou eux ont pu
aussi exprimer leur émotion donc c'est
vrai que c'est intéressant pour eux
comme ils sont en difficulté scolaire
justement je trouve que la poésie est
plus abordable plus facilement abordable
en tout cas et les touches plus voilà
sur un sur un texte plus court je pense
que plus accessible en tout cas j'aime
bien quand il parle l'histoire
comment elle s'écrit les rimes et
surtout en fait qu'est-ce qui ressentent
on peut voir on peut aider on peut
s'exprimer avec la personne le prix
poésieveline est décerné conjointement
par le Conseil départemental la Maison
de la poésie et la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines il
doute le lauréat d'un prix de 3000 euros
et justement lauréate Rita mitsukusho
n'était pas présente ce mercredi à la
remise du Prix toutefois lors d'une
récente venue à Paris l'auteur inou a
tenu à adresser un message au collégiens
qui l'ont sélectionné je vous propose de
l'écouter
dois-je rallumer le feu sacré
mais toi rallume mon cœur
pour que mon esprit se porte mieux
ce feu doit revivre plus fort pour
réchauffer tous ceux qui vivent encore
ton message est celui de protéger la
Terre
je la protégerai aussi longtemps que je
vivrai avec elle
transporter nos rêves je crois vers le
futur ça représente beaucoup pour moi
parce que c'est des jeunes qui donnent
ce prix et je crois que les jeunes qui
aiment et qui lisent la poésie sont des
grands visionnaires je sais que pour moi
écrire dans les deux langues est un défi
parce que ma langue maternelle est en
danger mais en même temps je me dis que
c'est un beau défi parce que on est
ouvert au monde alors je parle ma langue
maternelle je chante ma langue
maternelle et je me donne ce privilège
d'écrire en français pour vous pour les
gens qui lisent le français parce que la
poésie inou est universelle elle parle
de la terre de la mère des rivières elle
doit être transportée elle doit voyager
c'est une poésie qui est nomade
voilà pour cet auteur inou qui a donc
reçu le Prix poésie de collégien 2015 on
va continuer à parler poésie on n'a pas
un auteur inou en plateau avec nous
c'est bonsoir Sylvain hiver vous êtes
attachés de conservation musée de
Port-Royal à Magny-les-Hameaux vous êtes
historien de formation et vous êtes vous
lauréat d'un concours qui était réservé
aux agents du ministère de la Culture et
le 10 avril vous avez reçu le premier
prix poésie 2015 de ce concours d'abord
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi vous allez
souhaiter participer à ce concours vous
êtes historien tu achètes conservation
et un peu poète dans la rue apparemment
oui c'est vrai que ça vient du c'est un
petit anecdotique comme comme démarrage
puisque c'est vrai que je suis historien
de formation j'ai même un doctorat à
finir bientôt j'ai cette chance
extraordinaire de travailler dans ce
musée national vous avez un peu
délaisser votre thèse un instant voilà
forcément les terrains fait que on doit
aussi voilà être dans la médiation comme
on dit dans le métier mais c'est vrai
que ça vient du d'une réflexion en
voyant donc en tant qu'agent associé
puisque je suis aussi attaché à la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin autour d'un projet
sandersource et en voyant arriver cette
offre de participation au concours de
poésie sur le thème national de
l'insurrection poétique je me suis fait
la réflexion mais oui Port-Royal et une
forme historique d'insurrection poétique
en quoi justement c'est une au lieu du
jansénisme est une forme d'insurrection
alors c'est vrai qu'on le sait pas
souvent certains chercheurs l'ont montré
comme Tony Girard sur un livre qui
s'appelle le champ de la grâce qui parle
de la poésie à Port-Royal et c'est vrai
que Port-Royal les gens parlent
versifier peut-être même Pascal aurait
versé pour Royal en tout cas racine
c'est sûr on a c'est encore ces
problèmes de jeunesse il y a aussi
Boileau il y a aussi la fontaine qui ont
écrit ce qu'on ne sait pas peut-être que
d'autres personnes enfin d'autres
auteurs célèbres ont aussi écrit sur sur
Port-Royal
c'est le juge arbitre l'Hospitalier le
solitaire qui parle en fait qu'un
hommage au solide qui serait un hommage
aux solitaire de est-ce qu'on peut
justement rappeler ce cochon les
solitaires de Port-Royal est un peu
l'histoire de ce lieu quand même de
résistance qui à un moment donné a été
détruit parce qu'il faisait un peu trop
d'ombre oui bah c'est tout à fait le
thème aussi de ce sujet c'est que c'est
un lieu qui a un monastère évidemment
qui qui s'encre dans une histoire
religieuse une histoire aussi
intellectuelle et bien sûr une histoire
nationale et européenne à un moment très
particulier de construction de ce qu'on
appelle le classicisme français en tout
cas de cette moment très particulier de
l'histoire de France et d'Europe donc
Port-Royal va devenir un des lieux clés
un des lieux emblématiques de cette
affaire certains auteurs ont des belles
images aussi littéraires là-dessus comme
André freignot qui dit des herbes folles
de Port-Royal au tapis vert de
Versailles les deux versants d'un seul
jardin français vous voyez cette cette
circulation de cette histoire alors
écrire son planning pour vous ça a été
évidemment une une évidence et créer un
poème de deux pages et ça s'est fait en
plus très rapidement vous allez
inspiration tout de suite alors
peut-être que sa nature est depuis
longtemps sans le savoir c'est possible
parce que bon reste historien comme je
le dis un petit peu en
rigolant c'est une poésie d'historien
quand même donc j'ai pas la prétention
j'ai pas la formation littéraire
forcément pour pour ça mais peut-être
qu'à force de lire et d'entendre des
choses ça nous influence c'est le lieu
de toute façon est tellement fort que
qu'il a sûrement une influence et donc
c'est vrai que cette poésie c'est écrit
en trois jours parce qu'il y avait des
délais de réponse
dans les délais du concours en fait et
c'est venu en fait d'une discussion
aussi avec Jacques Fournier de la Maison
de la poésie qui je disais bah pour
Royal ça serait marrant de faire une
poésie dessus puisque ça pourrait
correspondre au thème hautaine nationale
il m'a dit bah vas-y alors je me suis
senti obligé d'y aller et apparemment
j'ai bien fait vous avez fait deux pages
et vous avez reçu le premier prix est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en lire un extrait
lire tout le poème qui est long
est-ce que vous nous en dire un extra
peut-être la fin parce que les gens qui
vont découvrir des choses je vous laisse
je vous laisse lire
aux sources occultes du classicisme
c'est donc bien cette insurrection un
jour baptisé jansénisme qui attira ici
notre attention on pourrait dire encore
bien des choses sur les écho multiples
qui continuent à raisonner d'une
expérience humaine loin d'être close
jusqu'au portes de notre actualité comme
au discours enflammé d'un certain
président Herriot dans les pas de
Grégoire sainte-bauve et même Victor
Hugo qui a la ruine du pays au sortir de
la deuxième guerre mondiale scandait
l'âme de la France et la leçon de
Port-Royal n'a-t-on jamais dit la chose
de manière plus magistrale mais à son
étonner ainsi Nathan final rien perdu du
souffle visionnaire d'une curieuse
martingale qui du génie français et
mondialement connu et répondant au nom
de Paris de Pascal là où réside encore
peut-être la clé du mystère Port-Royal
voilà donc on est à on est complètement
dans l'insurrection politique avec
notamment des propos du président
Henriot c'est étonnant de retrouver ton
Royal cité par un président c'est tout à
fait aussi c'est je pense cet étonnement
là en tant qu'historien et heureusement
l'histoire encore réserve de nombreuses
surprises et en particulier dans des
lieux aussi riches et complexes que
Port-Royal c'est je pense c'était cet
étonnement là aussi que j'ai
indirectement j'ai voulu peut-être
partager de c'est parce que c'est ce
discours du président Herriot a été
découvert il y a pas si longtemps il y a
même des chercheurs de Sorbonne qui nous
l'ont réclamé puis au moment de
constituer d'ailleurs ce centre de
ressources à au musée de Port-Royal et
dans notre acquisition on a découvert ce
titre là qui a été édité dans la revue
conférenciale mais quand le président
Henriot est Rio pardon parle de leçon de
Port-Royal il parle de quoi là c'est
quoi cette fameuse leçon est-ce que vous
avez été vous historien chercher la
raison alors c'est une évocation
culturelle littéraire et politique
sûrement d'une certaine histoire qui
veut que alors c'est la vision de ce que
j'ai la République des Lettres sur
Port-Royal c'est-à-dire c'est toute une
tradition qui remonte à racine
d'ailleurs Boileau et toutes ces
personnalités mais qu'on retrouve en
écho de manière plus ou moins critique
de manière plus ou moins distancier même
chez Voltaire on a des problèmes de
jeunesse de Voltaire qui qui réagit à la
destruction de Royal des champs jusqu'à
Jean-Jacques Rousseau Flaubert et
compagnie donc il y a toute une espèce
de Sillage voyez littéraire qui traverse
toute la littérature française des
vocations sur Port-Royal jusqu'à mon
Mauriac pour les plus récents et
peterhanque plus récemment qui est
encore passé au musée de Port-Royal il y
a pas si longtemps en tout cas qui a été
élu et donc voilà on a tous cette
tradition littéraire qui autour de
Port-Royal et un vecteur de de réflexion
en tout cas sur cette sur cette identité
alors là vous en avez lu un extrait et
si on veut entendre le poème en entier
comme ça ça fait monter le suspense il
faut se rendre le 28 mai à 18h30 18h30
pardon à la Maison de la Poésie donc à
Guyancourt il y aura une lecture de de
votre texte la lecture du texte et des
textes qui sont la plupart en tout cas
mis en référence dans un poème pour
justement donner cette écho
de lecture et d'interprétation en
réalité sur la mémoire du lieu on peut
historien et donc aimer la poésie vous
le trouvez vous êtes un lecteur de
poésie depuis longtemps alors c'est vrai
que j'avais dans ma prime jeunesse je
suis plus jeune j'avais beaucoup écrit
de poésie
mais que j'ai mis de côté dans un
classeur qui devait faire sortir
de continuer je vais voir si je peux
mais j'ai d'abord un doctorat à afficher
avant ça et
c'est vrai vous écriviez jeune de la
poésie mais vous en lisez aussi je
lisais beaucoup comme beaucoup aussi de
assezage de poésie de littérature de
choses un peu historiques philosophiques
c'est sûr que ça nourrit la réflexion et
à un moment donné ça ça prend forme et
ça mûrit ça c'est venu comme ça ça
nourrit la réflexion et qu'est-ce qui
vous touche particulièrement dans dans
la poésie alors c'est vrai que c'est ce
qui est c'est cette capacité que j'ai
découverte en réalité en écrivant ce
poème que certains comme Gaston
Bachelard des grands penseurs avaient
déjà soulevé depuis longtemps cette
capacité à s'extraordinaire qu'elle a
poésie de en très peu de mots de d'avoir
cette capacité d'exprimer des choses et
une compréhension en réalité moi-même là
je pensais pas quand deux pages on dit
qu'il y a pas de dire autant de choses
sur Port-Royal et je l'ai je l'ai je
l'ai découvert en le faisant vous l'avez
fait lire à son directeur qui puait qui
sera en plateau tout à l'heure dans
l'émission
c'est lié aussi à cette expérience du
lieu c'est collaborations sur
extraordinaire qu'on a sur ce lieu et
c'est lieux plein de projets de richesse
il vous en parlera il faut mieux que moi
la Nuit des Musées avant de se quitter
on va écouter un micro-trottoir on
t'adore les rues de 50 ans en Yvelines
pour demander aux gens ce qu'il est
touché particulièrement dans la poésie
on va les écouter ça ça correspond à ce
que vous venez nous dire
la musicalité
c'est agréable à lire c'est surtout les
mots en fait moi je suis très attaché à
la langue française et à l'harmonie des
mots et à l'usage qu'on peut faire avec
des mots donc la poésie c'est une belle
manière de rendre hommage à la à notre
langue qui est très belle et donc il
faut prendre soin des vers qui font du
moins les rythmes qu'il y a je sais pas
moi qu'est-ce qui me touche dans la
poésie et ben c'est le côté un peu
secret les mots
la façon dont ils sont disposés la façon
dont on les utilise ça touche les
sentiments l'amour
principalement voilà on comprend bien ce
qui touche les 50 chinois c'est les mots
et les l'émotion c'est ce que vous
disiez il y a quelques instants alors la
suite vous avez dit est-ce que vous
allez ou pas reprendre continuer
l'écriture c'est une envie je pense que
je présume que les réactions étaient
nombreuses on reçoit comme ça un premier
prix de poésie les réactions doivent
être nombreuses il y a des réactions qui
font bien sûr plaisir notamment de la
part de collecte de Sorbonne ou même de
l'Institut de France qui avait été en
travail dans le cas du musée qui qui
sont des spécialistes cette histoire de
la poésie qui qui ont vraiment apprécié
la chose et aussi des des personnes
impliquées dans les associations les
collègues bien sûr qui qui peut-être un
recueil complet de poème de Sylvain il
air qui va donc sortir de ses tiroirs à
l'époque qu'il a écrit quand il était
en tout cas si vous voulez entendre les
lectures de ce poème qui a reçu le
premier prix de poésie 2015 du ministère
de la Culture rendez-vous donc jeudi 28
mai à 18h30 à la Maison de la Poésie
merci beaucoup Sylvain être venu sur le
plateau du journal et si vous voulez
connaître un peu mieux de choses sur le
site de Port-Royal Deschamps donc à mon
on va en parler dans quelques instants
avec dans kiosque l'émission culturelle
avec son directeur Philippe lui et je
lui demander ce qu'il a pensé de votre
poème merci beaucoup Sylvain alors on va
continuer à parler culture ou plutôt
agriculture Paris fermiers initiative
originale des producteurs fermiers
vendent directement aux consommateurs
une opération proposée à la Bergerie
Nationale de Rambouillet elle est bon
produit sont dans le pré où il y a elle
aux commentaires
foie gras 8 ou fromage du Sud-Ouest à la
Normandie en passant par les Alpes le
terroir français était à l'honneur ce
week-end à Rambouillet à l'occasion du
Paris fermier organisé par l'association
nationale sitame fermier plus de 100
producteurs français membres de
l'association sont venus promouvoir leur
produit Daniel et producteur de foie
gras dans le Pays Basque et vient ici
depuis 5 ans
directe et on en profite pour revoir les
clients qu'on a sur Rambouillet et dans
les alentours c'est pour ça qu'on vient
ici on est habitué à faire des Solans
avec beaucoup de revendeurs et de toutes
sortes ici vraiment c'est trié sur le
volet et c'est vraiment que des
producteurs tous les gens que vous voyez
ici il faut qu'on leur produit eux-mêmes
l'opportunité de nouer le contact entre
consommateurs et producteur c'est le cas
de Christian producteur d'huîtres il est
ici pour la première fois ces collègues
qui m'ont démarché sur d'autres
marchés de producteurs de pays et qui
m'ont dit il faut venir à Rambouillet
donc
si ça pouvait marcher le Paris fermier
c'est avant tout un gage de qualité du
produit avec une grande diversité de
l'offre des visiteurs habitués qui
reviennent chaque année pour eux c'est
aussi l'occasion de goûter avant
d'acheter il y a des produits que je
cherche particulièrement donc là il y
avait du miel qui m'intéressait donc
j'ai goûté et voilà et je vais acheter
après je trouve que c'est une très bonne
qualité il y a des choses vraiment bien
des produits de terroir des donc après
on peut trouver il y a beaucoup de
choses il y a de la charcuterie du
fromage du vin
l'événement qui a lieu dans la Bergerie
Nationale de Rambouillet à attiré les
familles des animaux étaient également
là pour le bonheur des enfants au total
sur trois jours 13000 visiteurs ont fait
le déplacement prochain rendez-vous
au même endroit au mois de novembre
je vous le disais donc le bonheur est
dans le pré
à grands pas ce sera les 6 et 7 juin
prochain les bénévoles et organisateurs
multiplient les actions pour faire
connaître l'événement mais aussi
apprendre des aujourd'hui des
aujourd'hui pardon à consommer et vivre
autrement et vous allez le voir certains
ateliers sont plus surprenants que
d'autres Mélanie poquet
et si vous passiez aux toilettes sèches
et les créer vous-même c'est ce que
proposer des membres d'alternatives à ce
week-end pour commencer rassembler du
matériel de récupération un peu d'huile
de coude et d'imagination l'idée c'est
d'avoir un socle des murs un toit donc
construit avec toutes nos matériels de
récupération déjà on utilise pas d'eau
donc déjà effectivement on préserve
quand même les ressources en eau et en
fait si vous voulez la matière
organique créée tu utilisable en fait
dans l'agriculture et donc on considère
aussi que ça ça a un apport c'est un
juste retour en fait à la nature si
c'est encore difficile d'en installer
chez soi les toilettes sèches se
développent surtout en extérieur
notamment sur les festivals une chasse
d'eau de toilette normale use jusqu'à 12
litres d'eau pour remplacer cette
ressource les toilettes sèches utilisent
des copeaux de bois
une petite pierre l'édifice dans le sens
où
faut qu'on change un peu nos habitudes
les habitudes qu'on avait jusqu'à
maintenant et donc
changer chacun petit à petit si vous
aussi vous voulez mettre votre petite
pierre à l'édifice les organisateurs
recherchent des bénévoles le festival
alternatiba se déroulera à La Verrière
les 6 et 7 juin
ce journal est maintenant terminé merci
de l'avoir suivi en raison du jeudi de
l'Ascension pas de journal demain
rendez-vous de l'information vendredi à
18h tout de suite vous avez rendez-vous
avec le magazine kiosque magazine
culturel nous parlerons de la 11e Nuit
européenne des musées je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée